*so again the economy is doing well but
'we'are not, is it conversely possible for*
*us to do well yeah for the economy to falter?*
Imean in a sense it's a question on semantics
and a question on linguistics, I personally
think that a good economy is people's lives
being good, I think that's... you know I don't
think... I think they are the same thing but
you can definitely have a situation where GDP is
rising and people's lives are getting worse 100%
you can have that and I think that is I mean GDP
now is much higher than it was 50-60 years ago
but in many ways people's lives are worsethan
they were 60 years ago; they work longer hours,
they have much less leisure time, in many
casesthey're squeezed into smaller housing,
they're much more financially insecure; some things
havegotten better of course you know there's been
technological advancements you know holidays
to Asia are cheaper and a lot of white goods are
cheaper you know obviously we have computing
powerwe didn't have back then but you know in terms
of financial security you know I look at my dad with
no advanced education and you know god bless you
dad no particular marketable skills, he was able to
buy a house and raise a family you know nowadays
you have people who are homeless doing that kind
of job you know what I mean you know so I think in
many ways life has gone worse so I always remember
there was um a great moment in the brexit debate
where I think it was George Osborne was on I
don't know Question Time saying 'if we leave
the EU GDP is going to go down' I don't know 4.7%
or whatever and some woman stood up in the crowd
and she shouted 'that's your GDP' and um I f***in
loved it I thought it was amazing this is like
such a powerful statement for the reclamation of
economics and economic ideas for the f***ing people
who gives a f*** if GDP is going up if life is
getting worse and worse for the majority
of the people, it doesn't f***in matter doesit?
it doesn't f***in matter so um I think that
because economists tend to focus on very narrow
metrics you know if you look at the last 20 years
okay maybe not the last two years but before
that; growing GDP, low unemployment, low steady
inflation; in the eyes of most economists that
is a good economy okay maybe it's not excellent
economy but it's a good economy but if you look
actually what's happening to ordinary families
harder to get a well-paying job, harder to be
able to support a family, longer working hours
much harder to afford housing, so many parts
of this country and and this continent and
the world which used to be able to house good
reliable jobs for families you can't even live
there anymore it's hard to get a job you know what
I mean? yes it's not working for ordinary people but
um yeah it's it's to focus just on GDP is a
madness and I think I think um you need to
you know (Thomas) Kane said that to be a
good economist requires a great variety
of skills and I think yeah you need to be able
to look at GDP and understand it but it's just
one measure and if GDP is going up and life is
getting worse then who the f*** really cares
*so I mean like it is a case ofsemantics and
how you phrase it butif the problem is that
in the publicsector we're not very good at finding
out the good economists and rewardingthem
but in the private sector they are
how do they identify good economists?*
predictors! predictors!
well in markets it's just...
you set them out you compete against one
another and who's the guy who's getting them
making the predictions right? who is the guy...
that's why I'm so focused on... *what GDP?*
it could be anything it could be anything so you
know I was specifically and it's it's not just
that your predictions are right what they look for
what markets effectively reward is people who are
very good uh making predictions that are right and
everybody thought they were wrong so if everybody
knows something's going to happen you don't
make no money betting on it so my big trade was
back in sort of early 2011 I said interest rates
will be zero for f***in five years nobody thought
that back then, nobody thought that back then,
butI could see ordinary people are getting f***ed
here and you're never going to have a recovery if
people don't have any f***in money to spend you
know what I mean and um it wasn't that complicated
really but nobody could see that nobody could
see that and I think what you have there is
another big problem in economics which is that
top level economists either ones that come from
prestigious universities and get the prestigious
jobs overwhelmingly living lives where they are
from elite universities, elite private schools,
rich families.. everybody I know is from that
background and they have no f***in idea what's
happening in the real world they've got no f***in
idea so you have this whole world of economics
where nobody knows what's f***in happening
in their lives of ordinary people with regards..
it is crazy it is.. this is.. It's.. and youknow
you look at it and it's sometimes it's
profoundly depressing I think you have to look for
the humour in it in a way you know you look at these
guys like George Osborne and like Andrew Bailey and
youknow they look so smart in their suits they don't
know what the f*** they're doing they do not
know what the f*** and the worst of it is they
don't even know they don't know that's how bad
they are that is seriously this and and nobody
no good trader in the city gives a f*** about them
they know we know that they're a bunch of idiots
*scary* it's scary but you know you got me you
got me you know you you know you won't find
many who have a better understanding *in many ways
though and I'm sure maybe viewers would share this..*
*I wonder if maybe not having you would be better
ignorance is bliss* no no I don't I don't believe that
I don't believe ignorance is bliss I think that
there is a profound strength and dignity that
comes from working hard to understand the
situation that you are in even if it is bad